yo what's going on guys christy flakes
your off bleacher report and for today's
video we are going to be reacting to the
event made popular by the hit single
hanging out you're an all-star by smash
mouth and that is the 2022 nba all-star
starters and captains also do not
fact-check the first part of that
statement because it's not true i'm like
93 sure but what you can do is you can
go in the comment section below and let
me know who the biggest snub is because
every single season there's like one or
two guys that have a great case where
it's like yeah they probably could have
been a starter um but there's only 10
starting spots and also like abundant
like abundance of like talent and
certain positions and stuff makes it
kind of difficult right man but so let
me know in the comment section below who
the biggest snub is uh this article is
by adam wells let's check this out so
what we have here is the western
conference all-star stores east
conference stars we're gonna read it
like this and talk about each player
individually so for the front court we
do have lebron james no surprise there
nikola jokic andrew wiggins hey go see
andrew wiggins make the all-star team
there we go man uh we got steph curry
for the warriors and john murray the
youngblood of the grizzlies okay that is
a fun lineup like
ball movement the shooting the
athleticism yeah it's gonna be fun uh
for the eastern conference all-star
stars we have kevin durant yeah cooper
joel embiid demar derozan and trey young
so once again no huge surprises there i
feel like that's pretty good and i feel
like that's pretty good so yeah right
off the bat like what are your guys's
opinions are you liking the selections
or is there some aspect that just got
completely screwed up so let's go ahead
and hop over here to bleacher reports
instagram account and we're going to
kind of go through this like
individually one player at a time uh so
the first guy being the captain of the
western conference is going to be lebron
james no surprise here uh the the way
he's playing basketball this way in his
career and just the efficiency and
realistically playing some of his best
basketball of all time which you just
don't say that for guys that are that
old like you think about you know nba
players of years past that even made it
this far in their career um at this
point they're like a shout out of their
former self or some type of like role
player like lebron james is still the
best of the best out there so yeah man
no surprise there um then we got you
know steph curry now steph curry on this
season not his most efficient season but
even curry's least efficient seasons is
better than you know most seasons of any
other point guard out there man so yeah
so much fun to watch uh broke the
three-point record this season um dude
show time so yeah man steph curry making
it in the backcourt uh then we got
nikola jokic so joe kids on the season
putting up just as good of numbers
if not better than last year man when
you actually want to get mvp awards so
yeah when you're playing that great
basketball you definitely deserve to be
a starter so yeah man all looking
forward to seeing yoka do some of these
crazy passes in the all-star game uh
next we got yeah john rant man so this
one right here i i know like john murray
is probably one that people are looking
at and maybe thinking some other guys
deserved it um i'm definitely not one of
them i mean this grizzlies team has just
changed so much you know really since
drafting john ran to the team and giving
him the reigns as the point guard you
know moving on from mike conley a few
seasons ago it's just been so beautiful
to watch and uh i'm happy for him man
i'm also happy for the memphis grizzlies
like just having that franchise type of
player so young making his first
all-star appearance like you got to be
happy for me so much fun to watch too
like i mean
it's not like all nba awards or anything
like that like we want the fun players
out there to watch and john rant like
this dude is gonna be throwing down some
crazy dunks uh next obviously we all we
have uh andrew wiggins so okay so andrew
wiggins first all-star appearance
the way i gotta summarize wiggins making
the all-star game as a starter
is in the words of flight so
inspirational man because you gotta
think about it this guy was drafted into
the nba just with this um title of being
like the next great thing
since lebron james like those are some
big shoes to fill and you know
early on his career the t wolves uh
wasn't always the most efficient guy
sometimes took shots they probably
shouldn't have but since being traded to
the golden state warriors like he has
become an all-star within his own type
of role like just using his athleticism
um to make him a great defensive player
i smart the shot selection just really
being that like ultimate like blue guy
which uh you know normally i would give
that type of title to like draymond
green but i mean in this case like
andrew wiggins has done all the right
things to
not only fit but excel in this golden
state warrior system and they are a
better team because of him man so yeah i
am happy for andrew wiggins
i know it's stat wise maybe not as
popular as some of the other you know
names out there or maybe even just um
you know even with the numbers like
there's guys that probably have put up
better numbers but also you gotta think
about too like it's two guards three
forwards so um i know like you know
devin booker or donovan mitchell like
you can't give that spot to them because
different positions now if you want to
have the argument of maybe they should
get rid of like positions in the nba
all-star draft that would be kind of
interesting but uh yeah i think wiggins
definitely deserves it at least to some
extent i mean he made it so yeah and
then we got the 2022 mb all-star
starters right here um starting off with
the captain of kevin durant so he's
probably not going to play in it so my
prediction
is uh you know either jason tatum or
jimmy butler is going to take his spot
uh depending how you want to look at
that but uh yeah i don't think he's
gonna actually play in it now will he
actually draft the team he might still
do that i think he was injured last year
and i don't i don't remember he was the
captain last year now but uh yeah so
curious how that all kind of goes down
but i mean kevin durant coming back from
you know major injuries over the years
and still playing some of his best
basketball it's crazy like seeing some
of these uh
guys i've been watching for you know
forever and i will just really become
this great
off the circumstances of age or major
injuries like three like kevin durant
lebron is not taking step backs at all
man they're getting better and uh it's
insane okay uh we got
young santa cumpo uh yeah he's got that
bucks playing like another championship
team playing simple like you can't
disrespect the greek freak the numbers
he puts up what he means to milwaukee
and that entire franchise um
very welcome with another mvp this
season man defense player even too so
yeah kumpo very very well warranted uh
six all-star selection appearance uh
then for joel embiid
you want to talk about something that's
been on a tear like this guy's been
dropping like 40 point games 30 point
guys 50 point games over the course of
the past um you know like 10 games or so
and another guy that
you look at that philadelphia roster
it's so similar between him and mv or
him and all jokic where those are like
the two like premier centers in the nba
both winning of mvp numbers both have
rosters that are not at full strength
but still have their teams playing
at a great level and to me that's not
only an all-star but that's like mvp
conversation talk right there and then
we have over here uh demar derozan of
chicago bulls
i mean another guy you gotta be so happy
for a lot of people thought that his
style of play did not mesh well as far
as winning and success and everything
and he spent a few years with the spurs
and nobody really talked about him now
he was still putting up numbers in san
antonio but uh just nobody really talked
about it went to this bulls team fit in
perfectly with exactly what they needed
combined you know with zach levine and
lonzo ball and vucevic and uh yeah man
demar derozan's name definitely needs to
be up there as far as the most valuable
players in the nba but he is going to be
rewarded with his fifth all-star
appearance and then finally we got trey
young so so many talented guards in the
eastern conference um looking at darius
garland lamela ball you know kyrie
irving james harding guys like that man
but trey young
you know despite the hawks not being as
great this season it's not because of
him you know he's averaging nearly 30
points in double-digit assists like uh
once again when it comes down to
watching the most exciting players like
trey young's name is right up there as
far as point guards go man so uh he's
got a second nba all-star appearance and
i do expect him you know to really get
that hawks team going in the right
direction after the all-star break so
very deserving of it right there man but
you guys let me know in the comment
section below who was the biggest snub
and if you want to go a step further uh
based off the combination of these
players like which guys do you want to
see play together do you want to see
honest team up with steph curry again
trey young with lebron james let me know
in the comment section below but that's
all we have thank you all so much for
watching and peace out my friends